you know what i never understand tell me
someone who
always hates their ex
you know what i'm talking about i
totally agree i don't understand that i
totally i've had girlfriends before i've
had maybe three or four serious
relationships whatever they didn't work
out
i'm i could text or call any of my exes
and be like how are you you know
totally good it didn't work out we're
not together they would only say good
things i don't understand the person i
[ __ ] hate my ex the worst and like
that's every x like you said before
you know if you've been ripped off by
the last 10 people you've done business
it's on you
so i don't understand that like
always hating your ex
right i agree i totally agree i don't
know what that is i understand just
share your life with me let me tell you
about these six exes i dated who were
absolute freaking waste of time i wanna
and that's how the story starts yeah how
was your last girl oh she was how was he
last oh he was at this now some of them
are problematic but for the most part so
anyways going back to this
if a guy
is serious about getting married before
43 years old whoever this guy is
make sure as many people that you
respect
know what you're looking for
people that you respect not just anybody
that's just any uber driver who drops
you off okay people that you respect
know what you're looking for and let
them go to work well good luck out there
everybody everyone needs a little luck
on their side exactly i think we know
who's gonna get married uh before anyone
else here over there who eric yeah you
think so well he's good for him good for
him on where he's at okay
you know
i was really hoping you would
have a little honesty and
open open up the book a little bit you
know
i like you you'd like to keep things
close to the vest i get it but this
guy's and what else he's done he's
you've you've used bumble you've used
that i've been on some of them you've
been out there nothing serious has come
out of it so okay
is there anything else you know yeah i
think you've got some stories that you
could share but you're holding them back
you're gonna you're gonna talk or you're
gonna be i mean i don't know what
stories he's digging for i think what
he's talking about is your late night
yoga courses that you take
those are amazing yeah great
okay so let's go to the next story which
is because
low-key got some some internet game
kai does
low-key he won't admit it he won't say
ever whoever plays the card of i don't
care yeah is attractive that's kai's
game yeah i don't care is his game if
you want to find out who can care less
kai got your beat yeah kai could care
less and that's attractive to a lot of
people out there okay hopefully a lot of
women out there for him but you know
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]